on soir christian saint-palais merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
généraliser ces cours criminelles qui
sont présentés comme un gain de temps
d'argent et évidemment qui ont pour but
de désengorger la justice vous approuvez
alors je vais vous dire c'est exactement
ce que nous avons craint et ce que nous
avons exprimé d'ailleurs très vivement
lorsqu'on a installé ses cours
criminelles à titre d'expérimentation
nous at on dit on nous allez on les
installe dans cinq départements qui on
va voir comment ça se passe et quelques
mois après on est tombé à deux autres
départements dans les pyrénées
atlantiques
cette expérimentation nous nous l'avons
quantité parce que nous pensons que
c'est une justice qui sera et une moins
belle justice que celles qui existent en
cour d'assises
tous les observateurs de la justice en
france s'accordent à dire que la justice
est bien rendue dans les cours d'assises
françaises et donc quand on a voulu
expérimenter pour économiser de l'argent
tout simplement un seul but et nous
avons dit attention ne bradons pas notre
justice et ne renonçons pas à ce qui
fait finalement notre fierté de savoir
rendre la justice en prenant son temps
et surtout vous le savez en associant
des jurés c'est à dire des citoyens en
faisant intervenir les citoyens le
peuple pour rendre la justice dans les
affaires les plus graves et en la
chantant aujourd'hui que cette
expérimentation dont on nous avait dit
vous verrez nous en tirons les
enseignements si on voit que ça
fonctionne bien
eh bien on va s'en servir et on lance
pour l'instant un ballon d'essai pour
voir comment nous réagissons les ans les
autres et on risque sous prétexte
d'économiser de l'argent de multiplier
ses cours d'assises sans jurés
c'est vraiment je vous assure que les
avocats pénalistes sont très hostiles à
cette généralisation et c'est une cité
la chronique de
de la mort de la cour d'assises qui
était annoncé et c'est une étape
supplémentaire j'en étais sûr je l'avais
annoncé à plusieurs reprises
ça me déçoit mais ne me surprend guère
ça veut dire mettre selon vous que le
gouvernement en fait tu prends comme
excuse un petit peu cette période de
confinement d'épidémie du coronavirus
pour peut-être rendre pérenne un système
qui n'est guère acceptable pourvoi voka
oui je crois que c'est à dire que dans
un premier temps on avait diminué le
nombre des jurés puis on avait créé déjà
des cours d'assises spéciale
on avait voulu étendre leurs compétences
il ya déjà vous savez des cours
d'assises spéciale sans jurés pour juger
les affaires de terrorisme et de trafic
de stupéfiants en bande organisée on
voulait l'élargir on a
du sud diminuée aussi le nombre de
magistrats professionnels dans ses cours
d'assises spéciale on diminue en
diminuant dès midi et forcément on porte
atteinte à la qualité de la décision de
justice parce que moins on est nombreux
pour juger bien moins on est certain
d'avoir pris la bonne décision plus on à
échanger plus on a de chance de
s'approcher de la vérité et donc d'avoir
une vérité judiciaire et qui puisse
satisfaire l'opinion publique
et puis moi je suis très attaché au lien
entre le peuple et la justice vous savez
combien le peuple est désormais méfiants
à l'égard de sa justice et combien ce
lien de confiance est rompu avec les
vues et donc le fait d'associer les
citoyens directement au rendu de la
justice à la participation aux audiences
c'était un gage de rapprochement entre
le peuple et la justice
je suis vraiment seul le prétexte
aujourd'hui du coronavirus on va vous
dire on a pris du retard oui on a pris
du retard
c'est vrai et donc il faut rattraper ce
retard mais il ne faut pas tout
abandonné pour rattraper ce retard en
justice prendre son temps ça n'est pas
perdre son temps
notre essence un palais le rôle de
l'avocat comment ça va se passer
concrètement ya cinq magistrats
effectivement plus le jury populaire le
l'avocat défendra le dossier face à ces
cinq magistrats c'est ça oui c'est ça
c'est un peu en réalité c'est exactement
ce que nous avons dans les tribunaux
correctionnels pour les délits pour les
débits nous avons face à nous trois
magistrats et bien là il y en aura cinq
je vous annonce d'ores et déjà que dans
cinq ou six ans il n'y en aura plus que
3 parce qu'on ira il n'y a pas
suffisamment d'argent trois magistrats
suffiront bien mais nous plaît de riom
donc comme nous le faisons là et dans
les affaires délictuelles mais avec des
habitudes qui ne garantissent pas le
temps que l'on prend avec des jurés les
jurés quand ils arrivent ils découvrent
le dossier qu'ils ne connaissent pas du
tout et nous sommes obligé de tout
reprendre comme éléments à charge et
donc c'est pour ça que cela prend du
temps mais c'est pour ça aussi que les
hommes et qui sont dans le box ont le
sentiment d'être mieux juger c'est très
important vous savez d'être condamné à
une peine lourde mais après un procès
dont l'accusé pense qu'il a été réalisé
dans des conditions équitables
c'est ça l'essentiel merci beaucoup
question saint-palais avocat président
de l'association des avocats pénalistes
de france avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france